did prophet muhammad have a submarine
was he a jack cousteau the border
between the pacific and atlantic oceans
is like a line between two worlds
it's as if the two oceans meet at an
invisible wall which does not let them
flow into each other and mix their
waters
why on earth does it happen it is
impossible for a man to discover
and write a truth that science has
discovered only in this age
was he connected cell phone with uh jack
cousteau to jack who still give him the
message say look there's a barrier here
and he put it in the book
come on people think he has let free the
two bodies of flowing water
assalamu alaikum ingredients of peace
how are you guys doing it's your first
time watching the dean show subscribe
right now
hit that notification bell keep coming
back where we got exciting
programs for you ahmed shared
this next video with me ahmed's a great
brother an amazing brother loves the
dawah and
he thought that this would be something
great this next video
which talks about one of the miracles in
the quran
that if we can get somebody to do a
documentary on this
the same way this not yet muslim did he
broke down the science
of this miracle that's mentioned in the
quran so there's three things that
i'd like to accomplish here one is the
person who's already been investigating
he's already been asking she's already
been asking the question what's the
purpose of life why am i here
the last thing that they wanted to look
at was islam but islam just makes sense
and it has all the evidence to prove
that it's from the creator but they're
like
on the fence back and forth what he's
going to say she's going to say i'm
going to say you know my parents going
to say society you know how it goes
all the social pressures that maybe
inshallah
this can be a catalyst where they can go
ahead and take that bold step
and i'll help explain what that is at
the end two
the person who is now
first-time exposure and wants evidence
okay
and someone said watch the dean's show
now you're watching the dean's show and
after this here's some evidence this is
one point of evidence this is just
one evidence and proof that's mentioned
in the quran
to prove that it's from the creator the
heavens and earth because it couldn't
come from
a man living in the desert who couldn't
read or write
what was known as the trustworthy now
listen
uh one more and the muslim the one who
is already who's live in islam but he's
also vacillating between two worlds the
dunya and the akhirah
having a hard time establishing his
salah in prayer he needs
he needs extra jolt right an iman boost
inshallah this can be that so let's go
ahead and watch this
comment on it and then also connect it
with the ayah the verse that talks about
this
miracle this sign because the quran the
verbatim word of god almighty
is full of them so let's go ahead this
is an amazing video
that breaks down the science of one of
those signs
miracles in the quran so when you look
at the seas and oceans on the map you
might think that they just flow into
each other
it seems like there's only one big ocean
and people just gave different names to
its parts
well you'll be amazed how vivid the
borders between them are the border
between the pacific and atlantic oceans
is like a line between two worlds
it's as if the two oceans meet at an
invisible wall which does not let them
flow into each other and mix their
waters
why on earth does it happen we know for
sure there is no invisible wall inside
and water is water what could interfere
with its mixing the thing is that water
can be different too
the atlantic and pacific oceans have
different density and chemical makeup
the level of salinity and other
qualities one can see by their color
that they are far from being the same
the borders between the two bodies of
water with different physical and
biological characteristics are known as
ocean clones holoclines borders between
waters with different salinity are the
most spectacular
and this is what we see when the
atlantic and pacific oceans meet the
famous explorer jean cousteau found this
when he was deep diving in the straits
of gibraltar
the layers of water with different
salinity looked like they were divided
with a transparent film
and each layer had its own flora and
fauna heloclines appeared when the water
in one ocean or sea is at least five
times saltier than the other
you can create a helicline at home if
you pour some seawater or colored salty
water in a glass
and then add some fresh water on top of
it the only difference is that your
halocline will be horizontal and ocean
haloclines are vertical
if you remember a couple of basic things
from physics you might argue that a
denser liquid should finally end up
lower and less dense higher
if that were true the border between the
two oceans would look not like a
vertical line but as a horizontal one
and the difference between their
salinity would become less obvious the
closer they got to each other
so why doesn't it happen here well first
the difference in density of water of
the two oceans is not that great for one
of them to get down and the other to
rise up
and yet it's enough to not let them mix
still another reason is inertia
one of the inertial forces known as the
coriolis force influences objects when
they are moving in the system of axes
which in its turn is moving too
in simpler words the earth is moving and
all the moving objects on it will be
acted upon by coriolis force deviating
from their course
as a result the objects on the earth's
surface don't move straight on but
deviate in clockwise order in the
northern hemisphere and counterclockwise
in the southern
but the earth is moving slowly it takes
a planet a whole day to make a full
circle around its axis
that's why the coriolis effect gets
obvious only in long time intervals with
cyclones and ocean flows
and this is why the direction of flows
in the atlantic and pacific oceans is
different
it also doesn't let them mix another
important difference between the two
oceans water
is the strength of molecules connection
or surface tensile strength
thanks to this strength molecules of a
matter hold on to each other the two
oceans have a totally different surface
tensile strength
and it also doesn't let them mix maybe
they could gradually start mixing with
time
but as the flows in them have opposite
directions they just don't have time to
do this
we think that it's just water in both
oceans but it's separate molecules meet
for just a short moment and then get
carried away with the ocean flow
don't you think though that only the
atlantic and pacific oceans don't get on
well with each other
there are a lot of places on the planet
where water in the two seas or rivers
doesn't mix
there are also thermoclines borders
between water of different temperatures
like the warm water of the gulf stream
and much colder north atlantic ocean
chemo climbs are the most amazing ones
these are borders between waters having
different microclimate
and chemical makeup the sargasso sea is
the biggest and most widely known
chemical line
it is a sea within the atlantic ocean
which has no shores but you've got no
chance not to notice it
let's have a look at some other
spectacular climbs on the planet did
prophet muhammad
have a submarine was he a jack cousteau
because now we're going to connect it
with what's mentioned in the quran now
this is not something nebulous
it's something very lucid and clear and
it is in a book that was compiled over a
span of 23 years piecemeal
and we have it today it's a living
miracle it's a sign for those who are
looking for the truth
now you can go ahead and be remiss in
this and just brush it off
and this is not something like
nostradamus vague attempts to try to
guess something
and then a person guesses a thousand and
one things
and a thousand of those things are wrong
completely
and one is kind of okay no see whatever
prophet muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him
whatever he was told and whatever he
conveyed
was a hundred percent accurate just one
thing if you find
of a contradiction in the quran it can't
be from the creator of heavens and earth
we're specifically focusing on this sign
on this in the quran how did
now we're going to get into connecting
it and let's see for the person is their
first time a
being exposed to this first time being
exposed to islam the quran
this can be a catalyst for you to
investigate further than the person
who's already been
vacillating back and forth and you know
looking into it
and it makes sense the whole concept of
the creator that he's won and alone
worthy of worship
you've investigated a life of prophet
muhammad you've seen the moral teachings
of the quran you've seen many of the
evidences
god willing this kicks it off and we can
take this this next step together
and then the muslim also vacillating
back and forth between the dunya and
ahira
and not establishing salat maybe this
can also be a iman booster now let's see
what the quran actually says
regarding this barrier that prevents
the two from mixing
he has let free the two bodies of
flowing water
meeting together between them is a
barrier
which they do not transgress
the expression of the verse has a
mind-blowing style
four the verse informs us that the seas
do not mingle with one another
despite all storms and huge waves
yes this is translated from the science
confirmed english verses of the quran as
it always
proves that it is the word of allah
it is as follows this is one just one of
the proofs
the french how would this man know that
how would he know a man in the desert
who is famous for underwater research
explains
think about it water barriers as follows
[Music]
we were investigating of some
researchers judgments that put
forth that there were some barriers that
separated different masses of the seas
from each other
as a result of various studies we saw
that the mediterranean sea has a
peculiar
natural level of salinity and density
at the same time it has specific life
forms
then we analyzed the mass of water in
the atlantic ocean
and saw that it was completely different
than the mediterranean sea
however these two seas which merge at
the strait of gibraltar
were supposed to be eager or at least
near to equal
in terms of salinity density and life
forms that they had
however these two seas have different
structures
even in places where they converge
closely
upon our investigations we came across
an event that amazed us
there was a great water curtain at the
merging point that did not allow these
two seas to mix
[Music]
the same kind of water barrier was found
by german scientists at bab al-mandab
where waters of gulf of aden and red sea
converge
in 1962
in our later investigations we witnessed
the existence of the same kind of
barrier in
all merging points of seas that have
different characteristics
this amazing fact which amazed captain
cousteau
about the waters that do not mix up
those seas converge
is explained with the following verse in
the quran
14 centuries ago
he has left bodies of flowing water
meeting together between them is a
barrier which they do not transgress
[Music]
another kind of water barrier on earth
is seen at
bays and deltas where the freshwater
rivers flow
into the seas
[Music]
rivers that have the utmost possibility
of mixing into one another
because of their surface and bottom
currents never mix
with salty water in places where they
fall into seas
if allah did not put the law of not
mixing up between these two waters
the freshwater rivers on earth would mix
up with the salty sea water
and the living creatures within them and
their environments
would be annihilated all together
the quran attracts attention to the
miracle of this
not mixing of these fresh and salty
waters in another verse
as follows
[Music]
dead bodies of flowing water water one
palette
and sweet and the other salt and bitter
[Music]
yes the fact that the seas do not mix
with each other
and the freshwater rivers do not mix
with salty waters
shows the infinite power of allah
it's being expressed 1400 years ago in
the quran
proves that the quran is the word of
allah
you want evidence it is impossible to
base this information on a man's
personal discovery
who lived at that age it is also
impossible to base it on
all people's discovery who lived at that
age
it is impossible for a man to discover
and write a truth
that science has discovered only in this
age
on his own 14 centuries ago
only recently therefore
the quran cannot be the word of man
it is the pre-eternal word of allah
who is the creator of lands and skies
it's your decision now you got to think
you got to clear your mind of any
prejudices
all the negative stereotypes and all the
negative things that you've been taught
because the truth is always going to be
attacked so let's get that out of our
minds if you're humble a true seeker
asking the creator of the heavens and
earth to guide you and you're here hey
this is a sign
and this is one of those signs was
prophet muhammad who's the last and
final messenger sent to mankind and
again again i always repeat this when
you accept prophet muhammad you
automatically you don't exclude jesus
moses abraham all the preceding
messengers who came with the same
message that prophet muhammad came with
worship one and only one god they were
for that time he is till the end of time
for you and me
right now living he's a mercy to all
mankind and he brought the guidance the
quran
not to worship him not to worship a
stick stone a bone a human being or
anything in creation
but to worship the one and only creator
that has an earth and to live to be a
morally upright human being
simple message easy to understand so
again before we conclude
did did prophet muhammad did he had a
submarine was he connected cell phone
with uh jack cousteau did jack who still
gave him the message say look there's a
barrier here and he put it in the book
come on people think did he have a drone
maybe he went up and he looked over did
he have a lab
a chemistry lab that he can go ahead and
take this water and
put it to the test and figure these
things out like it was broken down
by this not yet muslim non-muslim in
this video
so these are things really to ponder and
think about now
let's go and finish it off for that
person is like i've had enough eddie
that's
it we can die tomorrow because it's not
promise
it's not promised that you'll reach
tomorrow or the end of the day
and you're ready and you know about the
description of the hellfire in the quran
so you want to avoid the hellfire you
want to get the paradise and you want to
be connected to your creator
you want to be thankful to your creator
go ahead and repeat after me because now
is the time if you're going to pick any
time
do it right now seize the opportunity
repeat after me let's do this
that you declare that there's nothing
worthy of worship you've already looked
into islam you looked at the evidence
this is just another proof
on the abundance of proof compounded
over and over
and now you're ready to take that step
because why delay it any longer
and then at the same time you now you're
ready to live your purpose
so let's go ahead this is that first
step that a person takes they take the
shahadah ash
muhammad that you
bear witness that you testify you swear
that there's nothing worthy of worship
except the creator of the heavens and
the earth
that he's one and alone worthy of
worship and that you testify and swear
that muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him
is his prophet his messenger he's the
seal of the prophets
and if you're a christian coming along
that you also testified that jesus
peace be upon him was the son of mary
who was a slave and servant of god
almighty allah that's it
you're taking that first step and for
for all those out there who
are going to continue to journey
continue to explore continue to seek
seek guidance from the creator that
helmets on earth to guide you got to be
sincere you got to be genuine put your
prejudices to the side
also if you have any more questions call
us 1-800-662-islam
operators are standing by to answer your
question i want to thank ahmed
sheikh ahmed for sharing this with us
may god almighty allah put this in your
scale of good deeds
and for everybody out there now muslims
again who are on the truth hopefully
this is a a boost
a jolt to get your iman up start taking
this deen seriously because
this is mentioned but there are also
other things mentioned the consequences
of not fulfilling your responsibility in
this life the consequences
of not living the true purpose of life
you don't want to take this deen as a
joke get well grounded in it
live by it and look towards
the ultimate goal and that's the
hereafter that's jenna that's where we
want to be
set the gps agenda thank you guys for
tuning in and subscribe if you haven't
already
hit that notification bell and share
share this far and wide get in
on all the rewards support us on our
patreon page we'll see you next time
here on the dean show
thank you very much jazakallahu
assalaamu alaikum